tax season starts a little later this  year the irs will begin accepting tax  returns february 12th  the delay allows the irs to test its  systems after congress passed a second  round of those stimulus payments back in  december  some americans will be able to claim  those payments through filing instead of  just getting it in the mail  free help in with your taxes is  available for people who make less than  sixty thousand dollars a year if you're  one of those people  you can set up an appointment with hope  link of southern nevada the number on  your screen 972-8106  start january 30th there'll be fridays  and saturdays  you can also drop off your documents  documents for preparation  we have more information at  eightnewsnow.com